borel douarec cet endroit c'était un mec
bien
le meilleur d'entre nous tu sais de quoi
sont bordés les sentiers anglais de pub
alors sérieux elle est où ton âme
vas-y mollo sans riante sud ouest on
passe par là essart et du trajet de
moitié à travers la forêt ouais on
aurait dû aller à vegas bas même labatut
serait connu dans un truc dit c'est
juste moi ou c'est vachement silencieux
par ici
ça a été vite serré ça pour être des
chasseurs une sorte d'appât possible il
montre pas ce genre de trucs dans les
documentaires un avertissement on
devrait pas être là mais [ __ ] on est
où là on va planter les tentes [ __ ]
les gars là c'est du n'importe quoi tu
vas finir trempé en temps ça j'entends
rien du tout la même toit
à
bon alors on en parle ou pas c'était un
cauchemar fils à toi était arrivé quoi
c'était flippant et on a tous super mal
dormi ok regardez regardez sa personne
tu as fait ça que tu t'es fait ça tout
seul
pourquoi il faut tout le temps que tunis
que je me dis parce que j'ai aucune
confiance en ton jugement tu vas pas
nous lâcher
ok
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc
même pas venu du tarn
[Applaudissements]